[Music]
in bad build new submitted by Jose Fran
oh I have friends
no no singular singular I have a new
friend
[ __ ] your buddy new bad a man dies after
crashing his home boat racing cart
nicknamed the death card oh that is he
called it yeah yeah he calls it he saw
it coming
is that sad or ironic I mean I really
like the name no is it I think it's
ironic no don't you think that no why is
it not ironic boy ironic I already is
like you know when it actually happens
when rains on your wedding day
yeah it's like we ride when he already
paid no smoking sign on your cigarette
break it's like it's like it's like the
good advice that you just can't take
yeah okay so this 24 year old he lost aw
I don't know what the [ __ ] is talking
about the more sad lyrics with the sleep
Sylla yeah wedding day it's a free
oh I see see people say I'm not gay
please to my wife at my wedding yes this
24 year old he made this 1994 Honda
Civic into a cart like a legal
street-legal go-cart having a Honda
Civic an actual cart until you went the
other way around
oh oh that's fine that'll cool you did
it himself that's fine you used to be
able to buy a used Honda Civic for $500
back in the early 2000s you could buy
one now probably got a couple rent
oh really yeah how do you know that you
looked it up for your garbage car
collection actually yes I want a garbage
car collection you know people always
[ __ ] make fun of you because that's
Jim I don't know why I like garbage cars
because your element
I like cars that I used to want when I
was a kid and I still want it he wants
that [ __ ] Honda truck a Ridgeline
that's pretty much your name you don't
want that but did you see the technology
inside that thing and just get a [ __ ]
Honda they're not known for trucks why
don't you stop cursing at me for one
Ridgeline like a now sorry I just want
what I want okay I want a 92 Civic with
one spare wheel in the back that barely
works all right doll that's all I want
do you wanna you want the kind of the
Honda truck where when you take a hard
right turn Nestle flipz over yes like
that like you you don't want the wide
[ __ ] you want that [ __ ] I just want
every car that nobody wants that's like
my [ __ ] but I don't want anything
special on it I just wanted to look like
it came straight out the factory
brand-new in 1992 stop
yeah stock is [ __ ] just clean his own he
just wants a car that's gonna get
everyone a Kia that's what really who's
like this rich [ __ ] you know what if
something happened to my Honda Element I
was like it fulfill this purpose cuz
okay a golf ball get in that wasn't
there before I looked it I was like it's
a Honda Element gives it personality
yeah I was just kind of like and I
thought about it too when I was thinking
about fixing all the dents and scratches
what's the point yeah okay I bet you
took like someone's parking space and
you'd even notice you know that could be
[ __ ] no it was it was in his garage
someone broke in and killed itself
terrible someone if somebody just
scratched it over yeah it was Meryl
she's like you left the toilet seat up
the next day she was like [ __ ] cut
back she just drew a [ __ ] Minnie
Mouse on my cards quiet was man quiet
ones with bangs I don't trust him I
think it might be the Mini Cooper that
I've always make fun of every morning to
the parking attendant I think it might
be the parking attendants Mini Cooper
someone hasn't the Mini Cooper it's you
know how small that [ __ ] is right yeah I
keep talking about it but they [ __ ]
Park in them they parked in two spaces
always yeah in the same spot me Cooper
guys I don't appreciate this line oh
[ __ ] this is not a good bit I have a
Mini Cooper [ __ ] not the [ __ ] Mini
Coopers in fact there's a small scar on
earth and it takes two spots every
[ __ ] that's pretty silly
I'm always clowning on that guy and I'm
pretty sure the parking attendant that
I'm planning on with is actually his car
oh no I'm doing it too just laughing
there's some new BMW that's so small
that a Mini Cooper honor me I was
walking around neighborhood with Nikki
and I was making fun of how small a
small dude that the new whatever Z's
like the one series yeah it's crazy
small it's like this table sized like
it's that small I might I'm a hell do
you get into this thing I look back at
this I mentioned the story before on JK
news but there's a guy who owned a Mini
Cooper he parked really close to me and
then I was trying to get out and it
tapped his little mini cooper and it
left like this little little tiny dent
which I said that it was there I didn't
see it you know I mean so it comes out
there screaming in my face and I'm just
looking back at it now and it got to
that point where literally I was so
thrown down with him and then everything
calmed down and he got a little scared
so he went back into his Mini Cooper he
clammed up quick but either way I look
back at it I was like what a funny sight
I think this guy just this bucket like
six foot two guy comes out of this
[ __ ] Mini Cooper starts yelling at me
and it's just like this is a really dumb
situation is it Steve
no who's that I'm 6 4 yeah
haha but it was kind of like what was
the point like what are you so proud of
it's your orange Mini Cooper yeah I mean
rails red mine's red damn straight I
want to get hurt like that yeah yeah
why's the death machine why'd he call it
that well he put a full-on car engine on
a into it like old card no he turned a
car into yeah he went back yeah that's
what I'm saying a car engine on a
go-kart frame no no let me see the
picture he looks like a long name yeah
but it's a Honda Civics engine right
it's still a civic chassis is everything
with the chassis nevermind the bone the
four wheels are here it's that thing
yeah the metal yeah I don't know the
whole thing he made it I don't know so
he made the whole thing painted orange
got it when did you become a card spirit
if that's amazing so anyways if you guys
mean the chassis yeah oh yeah yeah
because I think that's still the front
end of the Civic so anyway he got hit by
a Pontiac and he was ejected it was yet
a stop or something no he was on the
highway and then he lost control of
somehow and like he went into the
oncoming traffic and then Akane
hit him [ __ ] and [ __ ] blew him out of
the does have a roll cage I can't really
tell from this ain't no because if he
had a roll cage he would even find it
that would have helped yeah well you
gotta ejected out of his chair that's a
Japanese car drivers nightmare both
straps see fellas my mom my mom always
like oh you have to buy American because
a metal could kill the little Asian car
yeah they're reporting that if he was in
the regular Honda Civic he could have
totally survived that but no but that's
not as fun well he made this car he was
I guess fun a scar though yeah it's way
more fun I would have taken to the
streets but I would take it to the track
off-roading I definitely would have take
it on the freeway yeah so this is I'm
sorry dude that's her is he in the Navy
is he black Mexican or Asian oh I was
looking at the passes Dillard I don't
know I was looking at that [ __ ]
fighter jet engines
well he's racially ambiguous but it's
pretty cool that's sad he made something
he just wanted to have more fun in his
life but he also named a death car maybe
he just put it on the back and he and
the pastor's invitation nobody really
wants to die they just
like tippy-toe with death but his
license plate was so hopeful it's his
cart life
oh I thought his license plate was like
death cart data card and then somebody
the back read it he goes oh really
and he hits him then he flew up damn no
I was that's true that's like people
want to live with danger they don't want
to die you want a tango
what type of Pawnee they want to tap
dance with danger it was a hot like a
Firebird it just says Pontiac hey you
could buy tanks you know that no you can
for cheap thirty thousand dollars babe
30 G's Oh dad what can you do with this
what depends on what kind and how good
condition yeah I'm you living it well I
think they like turn off the guns but
yeah they disable the gun I like how you
thought you we needed that clarification
well he wanted to warn any potential
buyers I had to break the sad news
because I was personally thinking about
shooting some [ __ ] wasn't that one you
two rushing him crazy youtuber that was
FBS Russia yeah that guy what didn't yet
he went to a place where that you can't
it cost money to do that right yeah I
think it was in a state where he could
do all kinds it's like Georgia they
don't let you shoot out of the tank but
they let you run over cars with the tank
I mean that's all I need to do anyway
it's 2 grand if you want to do it is it
yeah how about to get in a monster truck
into drive all over cars because that's
all I think I want to do the monster
truck monster truck right yeah I don't
know how much that one is I want to see
it with the tank I feel like I only have
this vision do we should go to monster
truck on a tank you're on you're like
you're on that [ __ ] whole thing and
you're like you look at me they still do
like gravedigger and all that stuff it's
like sunday sunday sunday sunday
Tarina was the the blue one it was the
big [ __ ] Chevy or Bigfoot big Bigfoot
that one was [ __ ] my child my
favorite moment there dude it's so weird
like I just remember liking it a lot as
a kid and I just don't remember when I
stopped liking it I loved it and I never
even saw that same and WWF was Wow
yeah it won't seem crowd I never watched
the monster truck well as a boy you just
love monster trucks yeah why'd you
suddenly WFO know is so don't wait i
watch the WWF when you see WTF i watched
it back when Ric Flair was on you know
I'm saying like all the good Bam Bam
Bigelow Million Dollar Man
I'll do the diet oh I'll do the Chinese
Yokozuna vs. earthquake i watch that
live on Raw what was the Undertaker used
to [ __ ] come on in a pre-trip bull in
the [ __ ] don't whack the bushwhack
brothers bushwhackers either this [ __ ]
the legion get a rub and tug boat
[ __ ] rub and tug boat the tugboat and
he doesn't exist
he didn't exist there is come there is a
time out helping you both there is the
guy who'll get on camera a jerk-off I
need to tell you that too that your
parents like Joe you guys remember the
[ __ ] jack off do of all there is
yeah I think you said the rubber dog
remember the [ __ ] coming out twins
that's crazy right remember the jerk-off
boys
[Music]